I think about what's happening today in
the professional world especially people
were thinking will a new ways of doing
business in a lot of ways just boils
down to what are you going to manage and
how are you to prioritize a calendar is
a really important part of a social
network because it actually tells what
am i doing and where am I going and with
whom I got the checking guys like
foursquare and gowalla which is all
about where are you right now and and
Tracking's are your footprint through
life we've got all these social
applications and location-based services
that are out there now that everybody's
flocking there's the calendar guys that
have a lot of data that we kind of want
but it's it's not in the right kind of
context that's why I like tundle because
it uses google calendar doesn't try to
replace her doesn't try to go no you
can't use google counter sorry it uses
what what works it's sort of Flipboard
same thing right Flipboard looks really
cool but underneath it's all too later
it's the same information standard is
still your Twitter feed but this way
differently because it's a better way to
look at the information so i think we go
to do the same thing with it KOAN just
several years ago people thought of you
know why would you do x startup idea
because google is just going to do it
right don't really says that these days
i think cuz we've seen google try to go
outside the core competency several
times and just not be that killer sort
of force that people fear that it would
be and so i think the same thing applies
to you know facebook it's like we're at
this period of time where people think
oh well facebook can do it and like yeah
they could but doesn't mean they will
you